From there.
Today we're continuing our summer sermon series
through Romans 12,
and we're examining what a transformed life in Christ really
looks like as we realign ourselves as best we can, but,
but by the Holy Spirit to the standard of Jesus, the perfect
vertical of Jesus.
As we get into it today, I want to tell you, uh,
about a story of a, a woman.
You might know her name, Rosaria Butterfield.
Now she has a powerful story.
She recorded it in a book called The Secret Thoughts
of An Unlikely Convert.
Now, her story is powerful
because for part of her life she was a professor
of women's studies
and she was living a same-sex lifestyle,
even hating Christians
and working against them in, in many active ways,
writing articles and books about it.
And that was her life until till the pastor
of a small church and his wife befriended Rosaria,
invited her over for meals and,
and had practical needs met in her life and prayed for her.
And they built a relationship with her.
And over time it built this deep connection.
And she says that they never pushed her.
Uh, they just loved her.
They cared for her, answered questions if they could,
but really just was caring for her as a person.
And a few years later, uh, one day as she was happening
to be at the church, he was preaching a sermon.
And, and in that moment, God opened her heart
to believe the gospel to be changed
by the gospel completely.
Her life is totally different now.
It's a powerful picture of what God can do
and she attributes that first
and foremost to the Lord and what he did.
But she also mentions the radically ordinary hospitality
of that pastor and his wife.
They were Christians who sought out this woman
who was opposed to God, who,
who many Christians would have nothing to do with,
wanted to avoid her.
They sought her out and they invited her into their lives.
Well, that's the command we're going
to see in Romans 1213 today.
Seek to show hospitality.
And here's why this is so important
because I think most of us misunderstand
what hospitality really is when we hear
that word hospitality, most
of us assume it's all about having a big house or
or being able to host a lot of parties
and entertain people at your house.
And and that's hospitality.
Emily, when we were at seminary
and my wife, she heard from a woman that
to be hospitable you have to iron the bedsheets
that you put on people's beds.
Like if that's where we're going with hospitality
or big house, like we're all outta that one, right?
There's there's no way we could do that.
And some of us, like I don't even have a house.
Okay, well, here, that's why I'm glad for
what the Bible says about this topic
because it has nothing to do
with whether you even have a house.
It's about your heart. It's about what is in here.
And here's what we need, this, this reorientation
around this idea of hospitality
because I believe the very mission
of God flows directly through this concept.
This is how he's gonna reach the world first and foremost.
And so since it's that big a deal, we need to ask God
for help as we go into this.
Lord, we pray as, as we look at this topic, it's heavy.
Uh, there's a challenge here that we'll all feel.
And so, Lord, I pray your spirit would remove obstacles,
get, get things out of our way, in our minds
that we would be able to hear and receive and understand.
And as James says, obey
what you've called us to in your word.
But it's gotta be your work.
Lord, change us if we need it today. In Jesus' name. Amen.
So here's how we're gonna go about this today.
I wanna teach the actual language of the phrase
that we're studying in Romans 1213.
Just simply look at the meaning of the language
and then we're gonna hang four lessons off of it
as we seek to apply it.
And so we're gonna start in, in Romans 1213, just
that first word, seek When we dig into
that word in the original language,
that word is deko in the Greek.
And it means to pursue or to chase after
or to eagerly pursue chase.
Uh, follow something eagerly with energy
and pursuit
that in a sense you're intensely hunting something
you're seeking for opportunities to do that thing.
It's actually, we use that language like we,
because it's actually the same word used for persecution
in Matthew five 10.
Jesus said, blessed are those who are persecuted.
That's the same word. Dko for righteousness sake
for theirs is the kingdom of heaven.
And so the same word for seek in our verse is
persecution over here.
So think about how persecutor will pursue Christians
to mistreat them, right?
Like they have to go intentionally
after it to find the people to do what they're going to do.
So that's the first word. But
that last word hospitality is really interesting.
'cause basically in Greek they took two different words
and they mashed it into one word.
And so you'll see it on the screen. It's the word philia.
And so again, means nothing to most, but
but it's actually two words, Philo
and xenia put together as one word.
Now you might have heard a little bit about that first one,
Philo, it's the word we use for brotherly love.
Like the, the city of Philadelphia is the city of
brotherly love, right?
So Phila is philo, which means brotherly love. So love.
But that second part of it, Xenia means stranger.
It's where we get our word xenophobia from.
Xenophobia is the prejudice against
or fear of someone who is from a different nation
or a different tribe or a different group
and you're afraid of or going to stay away from.
That's xenophobia. It's this word.
It's those people we call aliens or strangers.
That's the idea coming across with this word.
And so as we see it, let's be very clear about this
'cause that word hospitality is the whole point of this.
Phileo, let's be very clear
that word hospitality in English in the original language
literally means love of strangers,
hospitality in the text, love of strangers.
Does that do a little bit different than maybe
what you walked in here with thinking hospitality.
So what that applies like is
that hospitality is not just hanging out with your buddies.
It, it's not merely hosting a party for your kids',
classmates that you already know all of them.
That's not hospitality.
Hospitality is love of strangers.
So that's what this means.
Well, now let's, let's take four lessons
and hang it off that foundation.
'cause we're gonna grow in the desires
to grow in obedience to this, right?
Applying this command. So here's some things we
need to remember.
Four things we need to remember based on what it means
as we seek to apply it.
Here's the first one. This means
that biblical hospitality is a pursuit, not a preference.
Christian hospitality is a pursuit, not a preference.
Remember that first word, seek it's dko.
It means to pursue, to chase
after, to follow eagerly
again in a similar way to
how people would persecute the early church.
And so we take that word, we flip it around.
And in Romans 12, 13 means we are to hunt
for opportunities to welcome strangers in the same
energy and intensity that people would persecute Christians.
I think Saul, right in Acts, he would, he would go
after Christians.
He was finding seek, seeking them, hunting them.
That's how we should be in our way of welcoming strangers.
It means hospitality is not passive.
It's not just sitting back and waiting
for the opportunities to come your way.
You're hunting, looking, seeking. It's also not optional.
This is a command, right?
It's not just that you have the, the right personality
or the right circumstances or comfort level with strangers.
No, this is a command for all of us to pursue.
It's a, it's a qualification for us as elders.
That's part of the qualifications.
But this is a command for all of us.
Some of us have the gift of it,
but this is a command for all of us.
It's not optional. It's an intentional pursuit
that we are seeking to show hospitality.
And that means even if it's dangerous.
'cause remember when Paul was writing this in Romans 12,
hospitality would have been dangerous.
That stranger they were welcoming could have been a criminal
for all they knew could have been carrying some
disease that they didn't know about.
It could have been somebody
that was bringing this burden on their limited resources
and it was gonna cost them something.
It was dangerous. Like the Good Samaritan parable.
This man pays for him for a year to to live
and be taken care of.
Like it's a burden on him to do that.
But he said, I'm hospitable.
Yet as dangerous as it might be, as costly as it might be,
God's word still commands this of us.
The active pursuit of opportunities to welcome others.
And so it's a pursuit, not a preference. And you know why?
Why is this so important? Why should we do this?
Because God pursued us.
We pursue hospitality because God pursued us.
This is so important and it's all over the Bible.
Like God built this into the fabric of redemption.
It's all over the Bible. God pursued us.
It starts all the way back in Israel in the Old Testament
as they were coming out of Egypt.
Leviticus 1933 and 34 says, when a stranger, this is God.
When a stranger sojourns with you in your land,
you shall do him no wrong.
You should treat the stranger who sojourns with you
as the native among you.
And you shall love him as yourself.
For you were strangers in the land of Egypt,
I am the Lord your God.
Did you notice his motivation?
God says, do this first because I'm the Lord and
because as I'm the Lord I brought you out.
You, you once were strangers in Egypt, but now you're not.
And so because you're not now, you can care
for those who are strangers.
You can love them like I loved you, I pursued you in Egypt.
You can pursue others in your land.
It is in the Old Testament. It's in the
New Testament as well.
This is Ephesians chapter two.
Verse 12 tells us to remember that you were at
that time separated from Christ, alienated
from the commonwealth of Israel, strangers to the covenants
of promise, having no hope and without God in the world.
Yet what did God do?
He welcomed us in as strangers into his family.
Verse 13. But now in Christ Jesus, you
who are once far off have been brought near by the blood
of Christ, like strangers
before now, not strangers actually in the family.
Verse 19. So then you are no longer strangers and aliens.
You are fellow citizens with the saints
and members of the household of God.
God built hospitality into the very fabric of the gospel.
'cause think about how he showed hospitality, right?
Jesus left the comforts of heaven
of his home to pursue strangers
and rebels like you and me.
He Made himself uncomfortable.
He ate with tax collectors and sinners.
Those who are considered outsiders. He went after them.
And then as he's doing that, he's now prepared a place
for us who were once strangers to now live
with him in his home forever.
That's hospitality, isn't it? Like God set the pace.
God set the pattern for us in his very redemption
of us that we can pursue in our mission.
Because think about it. When we truly grasp the reality
that God has welcomed us into his household, that
that God has made us co-heirs with Christ,
that he's built this eternal home for us.
Like when we grasp it, how can we not turn around
and eagerly welcome other
people again?
Because God pursued us first.
We can go pursue others.
Here's the thing though about this.
Many of us don't do this, right?
We don't pursue the stranger we, we avoid, we run away from.
So why don't we do this? It's clear, it's commanded.
It's in the fabric of the gospel. Why don't we do this?
Well, it's, it's the same reason we don't obey God
in all kinds of other ways.
It's because of idolatry in our hearts.
Because something has taken priority over what God said
to do in.
And we follow that instead of following the Lord.
And so I want to just identify,
there's probably way more than this,
but I wanna just identify three, three obstacles
that will will keep us from following this command.
Like three idols that that we will have to have to overcome,
like these obstacles, these hurdles in our way.
We're gonna have to overcome that in order to obey
what God has said to do here.
There's things in our hearts keeping us from doing this.
What are a few of those?
Well here's, here's the first one. It's the idol of comfort.
Man. We just love our rest.
We love our routines, we love our preferences.
So we don't seek to show hospitality. You know what?
Because it's disruptive to our plans.
This is what I wanted do with my afternoon.
This is what I wanted to do with my evening man.
It's been a long week. I don't wanna do anything on
that Friday night to go minister those.
Ah, no I don't. I want to take my time.
This is my time, my rest.
That's the idol of comfort
because hospitality is inherently disruptive to our plants.
It Will force you to be outside of what you wanna do
because it is not natural.
But just think about that.
God's love for us disrupted heaven itself.
It didn't, it needed nothing.
They could have, God could have kept it that way,
but no took on flesh to come to us,
make himself uncomfortable to pursue us.
He disrupted his comfort to come to us.
That's hospitality. The idol
of comfort will keep us from pursuing this.
There's also the idol of control
that keeps us from pursuing welcome
'cause strangers bring unpredictability.
Like you never know outcomes
or conversations, how things are gonna go.
Maybe there's something's gonna happen,
maybe something's gonna be said.
You can't control that. So yes, it's unpredictable.
It won't always turn out the way we hope it will.
There's an element of risk involved in hospitality.
And so what do we do? We want to control safety.
We want to control everything working out.
And so we just don't get in the mess.
But, but one of the fundamental theological principles in
our faith is that we believe in a sovereign God.
And so don't we think that if we obey what he has said
to do, that we can trust him with the results
of what he's told us to do.
Like God, this is a risk.
God, this looks a little costly, God this, he's like,
I know I told you to do it
and I'm gonna work it all out for your good.
Even if it doesn't look like we
think it should or want it to.
The idol of control keeps us from hospitality.
Then there's the idol of appearances.
Like we fear that our home might be
not, it's not good enough.
I don't have enough money to do that or,
or maybe people aren't really gonna need what I have
to offer or whatever it is.
And you think this is the way things look.
Certainly it won't look right or
or possibly even worse, this one, this one's probably worse.
We fear what people are going to think
when those people come over to our house
When We're seen at a restaurant having a meal
with them.
You know, Jesus faced the same kind of idea.
This is Luke 5 29 through 31.
Levi made Jesus a great feast in his house.
There was a large company of tax collectors
and others reclining at table with them.
And the Pharisees
and their scribes grumbled at his disciples
saying, why do you eat
and drink with tax collectors and sinners?
And Jesus answered them.
Those who are well have no need
of a physician, but those who are sick.
So there might be some religious folks
that grumble a bit about your pursuit of hospitality.
And the enemy will do everything he can
to keep you from doing this.
But don't forget, God welcomed us when we were
at our worst, right?
We didn't clean ourselves up to come to him.
He met us in the middle of the mess.
Why would we not welcome others in the middle of their mess?
And why would we be offended at someone else who's trying
to meet someone in the middle of their mess
because they're doing what God does?
Why are we not? So there's
gonna be obstacles, this idol of comfort, this idol
of control, this idol of appearances.
There's gonna be things in our way.
The enemy tosses these things in our minds,
but God has commanded us to do this.
And God empowers us to do this.
This says it's very heart.
This is in the fabric of the gospel so we can,
and listen, don't think it's gonna be overly hard.
It's gonna be like a masochist. You just love pain.
This is all costly to you.
No, listen, there are great blessings
as we walk in faith like this.
When you step out in faith in this kind of way
to show hospitality, to seek to show like you step into
that man, there are great blessings that come in your life.
Again, think about how we've been realigning our lives all
summer with Jesus's perfect standard with his life.
Jesus was the most hospitable person ever.
And so when we start to show hospitality, we are beginning
to realign ourselves with Christ.
We're conforming to his image.
'cause think about what happens when you show hospitality.
It realigns us by increasing our capacity for love.
I didn't know I could love someone that different than me.
I didn't know I could love someone like that.
It it kills selfishness as you gotta get outside
of your comfort and it starts to rip out those things
that you've held back for too long.
It cultivates sacrifice in your life.
Think is that not Christ-like love,
unselfish sacrifice
that is more Christ-like As you are forced to do that
in showing hospitality, it grows your heart.
So he grows you into Christ's image. That's a blessing.
But it also means God's presence is in a unique way there
as you practice hospitality.
So there's an interesting teaching Jesus
gives in Matthew 25.
He's talking about the final judgment
and he's talking of characteristics of true Christians.
And he uses sheep and goats
and he says sheep, the true believers are doing things
that the goats aren't doing with the right heart, at least.
And he, he says it this way, Matthew 25, this is 35 and 36.
Jesus says, for I was hungry, he gave me food.
I was thirsty. You gave me drink.
I was a stranger and you welcomed me. I was naked.
You clothed me. I was sick. You visited me.
I was in prison and you came to me.
Sounds a lot like hospitality, doesn't it?
But, but notice Jesus did something here where like he,
he said, I was this.
You did this to me. That they were in a sense doing it
actually to Jesus, which was confusing to them.
'cause they were like, Jesus, when did we,
and so that's what he, they say next verses 37 through 39,
the righteous will answer him saying, Lord,
when did we see you hungry and feed you?
When did we see you thirsty, give you a drink?
When did we see you a stranger and welcome you
or naked and clothe you?
When did we see you sick or in prison and and visit you?
Jesus, we never saw you do any of those things.
So how did we do it to you? Look what he says. Verse 40.
And the king will answer them truly.
I say to you, as you did it to one of the least of these
my brothers, you did it to me.
You did it to me.
I'm there. It's like verse two
of Hebrews 13 says, do not neglect to show hospitality
to strangers for thereby some
of entertained angels unawares
So here's what happens as we pursue hospitality,
we have no idea what God is doing in that moment.
We have no idea what he's doing
behind the scenes in that moment.
But what we do know is he has made that a holy moment
that his presence is there somehow uniquely, he's infusing
that moment to make it a blessing to us
because Psalm 1611 says, in his presence,
there's fullness of joy.
So if God is present as we minister to the stranger,
then we get joy
because we're with his presence
as we minister to the stranger.
What a blessing. And we get joy
from the Lord in the moment as we seek to show hospitality.
And so that's a huge blessing.
But then also, think of this, think
of the friendships you never would've expected you could
ever have with people who are so different than you are.
I just think about the international students
that we have here at our church.
The last few years, that number has just grown
and grown and grown.
And it is unbelievably special to watch
how God has brought people from Africa, Southeast Asia,
the Middle East has brought them to our doorstep.
And we have built relationships with each other
and we have learned so much from them
That I would never would've had the opportunity
to do any other way apart from being
a part of what God's doing.
Just think of the unexpected blessings that come
with friendships from people all over the world
who see things differently than you do,
who can help you understand how to walk
through life from their perspective.
It is a huge blessing.
Maybe the greatest blessing though, is that hospitality
that we're talking about builds God's kingdom.
It, it's one of the ways God builds his kingdom
because it builds bridges of gospel conversation
as you serve someone and love them and care for them
and meet the needs that they have
as you pick them up from the airport as a new student
to UCO, and you're driving home to their apartment
for 30 minutes and you're helping move 'em in.
All this stuff like that, think of the trust and care
and conversations you have
with someone in the middle of that.
'cause all they know is that you've cared for them
and love them, and they're
interested to see what you have to say.
That you get to model the love
that Christ has shown us in the way you treat a stranger.
And how it models then the eternal home
that God has prepared for us.
Revelation seven says, people from all nations will gather
around the throne of God
and even around the, the wedding feast of the lamb,
we're gonna eat together forever and share
and rejoice together with people from all walks of life.
What a blessing it is to get to taste that even now.
That's what he's given us as blessings.
So again, Christian hospitality is not merely being
courteous socially to every person.
It is a gospel driven, joy filled pursuit
of welcoming strangers for the glory
of God and for their good.
It's not about how perfect your home is
or how great of a cook you are
or how creative your party invitations are.
That's not it. It's about having a heart so captured
by God's welcome of you that it overflows into your welcome
of every person you ever meet.
And don't overthink this. It can be so simple.
Start small, but start now.
Just invite one person
or one family over to your house for a simple
meal this week.
Like you don't have to get out the whole adult Lunchable
charcuterie board thing and
get it all fancy and all this stuff.
Like just throw some paper plates out there,
get some pizza and say, Hey, come on.
Let's, let's have a dinner. All it's about is your heart.
It's not about entertaining or showing off or performing.
It's about I love you and care for you. Let's talk.
Look for the lonely person at church.
Invite them into your life.
Sit with you, care, care for them.
Offer your home for a Bible study or a prayer meeting
or something that, that we
can just say, Hey, there's got space.
Let's use it. Think about
your neighborhood or your workplace and,
and think about the people from other nations who've moved
there or even know that at UCO,
there are dozens, if not hundreds of international students.
At least 80% of them never see the inside
of an American home while they're a student here.
That's tragic and they're long.
They want it, they would enjoy it.
And you could talk to someone who has a completely different
religion, worldview, everything,
and just say, Hey, you wanna come over
for dinner once every couple weeks and just talk?
See what happens. It's not
that complicated.
Similarly though, like sit down with an immigrant
and just ask 'em their story.
Like you, you don't have to talk politics.
You don't have to agree on everything,
but just, just say, Hey, can I hear how you got here?
It might totally transform your view
of everything that's going on.
Have a conversation with someone who's different than you
politically, socially, ethnically.
Just ask questions. You don't have to try to debate.
You don't have to try to come at it with some angle.
Just say, Hey, can I hear your thoughts on this?
Tell me, tell me why you feel that way.
And just have a conversation.
Just try to be welcoming in that
our theme all week at camp was, as we go,
as we go about this, let's be praying
and asking God to show us
opportunities we might have been missing.
Like that person at work that you're now seeing like, wow,
I could have, I could have been a lot
more intentional with them before.
Yeah, that's who God wants you to talk to.
Pray for opportunities, pray for his eyes
that you might have been missing things
and pray for a heart that would want to welcome others
for the glory of God.
I met Sean in 2007, right
after we'd moved to Fort Worth so I could attend seminary.
Emily and I moved there and lived in an apartment
and right around the corner was an ihop.
And so, uh, I happened to meet a man
at our doorstep selling magazines.
And he was down in his luck. And so I said, Hey,
let's just go eat a meal at ihop.
And so I had my Bible out on the table.
I was sharing the gospel with this man, and a
and a waiter walks up And says, is that a a bible?
I say, yeah, it is. He said, listen, I, I'm sorry
to interrupt, but I, I've asked a lot
of people questions about that and, and nobody can answer.
Would you be willing to try and answer the questions?
I was like, yes, yes.
And so we began to meet nearly weekly for two
and a half years, and we'd meet at Starbucks
or Brahms or wherever else.
And, and, and even he came to our house a few times
and he got to hold our firstborn son
a newborn and experienced the excitement we had with that.
And then he also got to see us walk
through a miscarriage just a few months later
and to see the peace
and faith we had through it, plus
how our church family came around us in that process.
He saw all that from the inside.
Sean would regularly talk about
the difference he saw in my eyes that I had a peace
and a joy that he didn't have, but that he longed for.
See, Shawn's story is very similar to the first part
of Rosaria Butterfield's story.
Broken searching in every style
of relationship for life,
Yet denying his creator and his savior.
Now, I wish I so wish I could give you
that redemption moment, like in her story,
but I don't know if Sean's story has that.
We moved away and he changed his phone number after a while
and I lost touch with Sean.
I still pray for him. I have his birthday on my calendar
and I pray that we were just like one piece of the puzzle
for him, showing him Christian Love
by inviting him into our lives.
Like he had three car wrecks in two years.
We helped pay for car repairs.
His partner left him and he was broken.
And so we tried to care for him
emotionally through that journey.
And, and all these things were happening.
And, and so we were planting, planting,
planting much in his life.
And I'm praying that someone else will eventually get
to harvest that fruit.
I'm praying that someday he would find where I serve
and he would walk through those doors
on a Sunday and come down.
I would lose it.
I mean, I would just like,
and he's changed, transformed by the gospel.
I would just, I can't even imagine.
But I don't want you to think that I'm the hero here.
I pray that God worked through what we did
and tried to plant in his life.
And yes, but I think God's primary intention for
that whole process of two and a half years was to change me.
See, I saw Sean's life up close and I saw things
and heard things that I'd never seen or heard before.
He told me painfully how he had been abused
by church leaders in all kinds of ways
and how Christ so-called Christians treated him, said things
to him through the rest of his life.
See, from the beginning when he saw my Bible,
his question was about sexuality.
And he's trying to figure that out
and trying to wonder through that and,
and struggling with things.
And, and so he asked me all the time about that.
And listen, I never wavered on what the Bible says.
We disagreed on that.
But it gave me an empathy
For The struggle
That he has And what he's experienced
that led him in many ways to, that I had compassion
as I understood him more.
I had compassion for him
Because I genuinely loved him.
And I longed still longed for Christ to be his redeemer,
to take all of that and, and wash it away
and make him a new creation.
I i pray that that's what would happen.
But it felt deep in my soul. That was my longing for him.
And so listen, church, we are conditioned
to fear the stranger.
Our media amplifies the anxieties we
feel of the other.
But Christian hospitality is an act of faith over fear.
And it's a way to treat every person as the image bearer
of God that they are,
and to point them to the perfect image that we are aiming
to see their lives redeemed by and
and drawn towards like
it's grace and truth.
We can have both. It's possible to be both at the same time.
So here's the question. In a
gated community world, how are we going
to open our homes and our hearts,
Especially To welcome those
that the world casts off
who are strangers to God?
How, how can we do that today? How can we do that this week?
Let's pray towards that right now.
Lord, we, God we need you every hour.
We need you our one
defense, our righteousness.
You are our hope.
Thankfully God, our living hope that we don't have
to walk in pursuit of this, the challenge that it is.
We don't have to walk in this with any fear
that it won't turn out well.
We already know the end of the story
and you've called us to this.
God, I pray for our idols of our hearts, things
that need to be ripped out.
You'd just destroy those today
and be willing to be uncomfortable.
We'd be willing to be a little bit outta control,
to be willing to, to look funny to the world
or to even other believers
because God, our heart is to obey you,
to look for those who are strangers, dangers
to love those who others consider unlovable
because God, you did that for us
while we were enemies.
Crest died for us.
So Lord, may we be heart.
May our hearts be to obey you,
to seek to show hospitality in the way you've shown it
to us, for your glory, for their good,
and ultimately God, for our good changes us.
So help us Lord. But again, thank you
that you showed us how to do it.
Left the glory and comfort of heaven,
to pursue strangers like us to live the perfect death life.
We couldn't live to die. The death we deserve to defeat sin
and death and the resurrection so
that we can have a living hope that we celebrate in you.
God, may that so compel us
to live an overflowing life towards you
and what you have for us, for your glory.
In Jesus' name, amen. Amen. Amen.
If you're able, let's stand.